welcome back now the independent inquiry
announced today into the uk's handling
of the pandemic is sure to examine
whether early warning signs were missed
it's a question being asked right around
the world and a new book the premonition
a pandemic story
focuses on a motley group of scientists
who claim
they saw the coveted outbreak coming its
author is michael lewis you
may remember he also wrote moneyball and
the big short
the theme of foresight is common among
his books so that's where
our conversation began
it was very like a book i did called the
big short where you had this about the
financial crisis where you had these
people who had been preparing for
decades or more uh for just this event
and who who who could see before the
event occurred that
when it occurred we're gonna have all
kinds of problems
they weren't diagnosing the united
kingdom they were diagnosing the united
states
but our our paths were remarkably
similar and tell me a little bit about
this uh
group of of misfits that you found at
the center of them is
is the character named carter mesher who
was
sort of reinvented pandemic planning and
during the book of bush administration
in the white house
so this the strategies that countries
have been using the social distancing
and the closing of various institutions
all this arises from work that he and a
small group of doctors did
way back when and then you had once the
trump administration basically said they
weren't going to manage it
at the federal level it was up to the
governors to to manage the pandemic
you had this group of doctors they they
were they they're kind of a secret group
uh call themselves the wolverines who
were stationed in various parts of
american society
and who were running a shadow response
you know talking to individual governors
to kind of
try try to manage the thing as best as
they could but but i mean it was
that's not the way you manage a pandemic
it's like fighting a war by giving each
of the 50 states an army and sending
them out to go do whatever they do
so they knew what was around the corner
and they were trying to tell
the government trying to tell the
president trying to tell whoever
what was about to hit not only the u.s
but the rest of the world
why didn't we listen to them so they
knew in two senses they knew that
this was a this is a risk that was a
growing risk
there was an increased likelihood this
would happen but they knew in a more
specific way
that in january carter mesher
is is doing extraordinary things in
wuhan china
to figure out what's actually happening
and by january 20th he has a
a bead on both the transmissibility and
the lethality of the virus
which which would have triggered should
have triggered all kinds of responses in
the government
um and and what happens is you know the
gov
what we learn is that that at least in
this country
one we don't really have a public health
system we have five thousand
disconnected
local public health officers who who who
are you know some are brave and some are
not some are smart and some are not
but at the end that we learned that our
federal institution that was set up to
deal with this the centers for disease
control
wasn't actually equipped to engage once
the shooting started
it had become it had become a kind of a
risk-averse more academic institution
and and so
what happens is the institutional
responses is to not want to hear it
and i think it was because they they
knew they sensed to some level
they actually couldn't deal with it yeah
quite incredible i mean it won't
surprise you then that a report by the
world health organization released today
found crucial flaws
in the global response to the pandemic
and of course it wasn't just america
was it that that got so much wrong so
early on i mean
we have the same problems here in the uk
no no it's amazing how similar we are
with it that in june of 2019
a group of experts ranked all the
countries in the world according to
their pandemic
preparedness their ability to deal with
the pandemic and the united states was
number one and the united kingdom was
number two
and the united states has four percent
of the world's population we now have 20
of the deaths and the only country we
can point to
and say maybe we did a little better
than them is you
and the book ends in in quite a
depressing fashion doesn't it because
your group of experts say that this was
almost a trial run there
there is worse possibly to come so
it's it's depressing it was it was an
absolutely thrilling book to write
because the characters were so good i
mean it felt like a story but
but their view of the matter is we got
lucky
that it could be it it could and will be
worse
in the sense that it could be more
transmissible it could be more lethal in
children
um and and it could be just generally
more lethal
and and as one of my characters said the
woman who sits at the center of the book
charity dean says
um you know mother nature may have given
us a gift because
she's awakened us to the these these
fundamental weaknesses in our systems
that if we don't correct we're doomed so
what's the
the overarching lesson then do you think
that people who read the book
will take away i think that they'll take
away mainly
i mean this is going to sound strange
delight in the story because the
characters are doing such amazing things
but it's a story the takeaway is this is
what happens when you have extraordinary
people in a broken system
and and when the extraordinary people
are doing what they need to do to try to
save lives
they end up by their deeds sort of
describing what's broken about the
system
uh you do uh uh write some fascinating
books and of course you've had a huge
amount of success you mentioned the big
short the film do you think this will be
turned into a movie
if you got assigned any deals yet i have
over the weekend
universal pictures uh bought it and
i'd i'd kind of be surprised if it isn't
made
i don't usually say that about my books
i usually think they go into a black
hole and they may never come out but i
think in this case
yes i think it will probably be a movie